A SERIES OF STRIKES ON HAMAS
TARGETS IN THE GAZA STRIP.
BRET?
>> Bret: CONNOR, THANK YOU.
THERE IS AN EMERGING CONFLICT
TONIGHT BETWEEN THE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO KEEP THIS COUNTRY SAFE
AND AT THE ENGINEERS WHO HAVE
DEVELOPED THE MACHINES TO DO
THAT.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN TELLS US THAT
SOME OF THEM NO LONGER WANT TO
PARTICIPATE.
>> Reporter: THE U.S. MILITARY
IS DEVELOPING A FLEET OF DRONES
KNOWN AS GREMLINS TO SWARM THE
BATTLEFIELD.
IT'S WORKING ON ROBOTIC TANKS,
SUBMARINE DRONES AND SHIPS THAT
CAN DEPLOY FOR MONTHS WITHOUT
ANY HUMANS ON BOARD.
NOW AFTER TEAMING UP WITH
SILICON VALLEY, IT'S FACING A
REBELLION FROM HIGH-TECH
CIVILIAN ENGINEERS WHO DON'T
WANT THEIR EXPERTISE USED TO
DEVELOP ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
THAT COULD BE USED TO KILL.
>> OF THE TECHNOLOGY WILL TAKE
US RIGHT UP TO THE POINT WHERE
IT WILL BE POSSIBLE TO TAKE
HUMANS OUT OF THE KILL CHAIN.
>> A DOZEN GOOGLE EMPLOYEES QUIT
THIS WEEK AFTER MORE THAN 3,000
SIGNED A PETITION DEMANDING THE
HIGH-TECH GIANT NOT PARTNER WITH
THE PENTAGON ON PROJECT MAVEN, A
DOD PROGRAM ALLOWING COMPUTERS
TO REPLACE HUMANS AND WADE
THROUGH HOURS OF DRUM VIDEO.
QUOTE WE SHOULD BELIEVE THAT
GOOGLE SHOULD NOT BE IN THE
BUSINESS OF WAR, SO WE BELIEVE
PROJECT MAVEN SHOULD BE CANCELED
AND A GOOGLE DRAFT A POLICY
STATING THAT NEITHER GOOGLE NOR
ITS CONTRACTORS WILL EVER BUILD
IT WORK FOR A TECHNOLOGY."
>> THE PENTAGON IS COLLECTING SO
MUCH DATA OFF OF DRONES, THEY
CAN'T POSSIBLY PUT ENOUGH PEOPLE
ON THESE VIDEO FEEDS TO ACTUALLY
WATCH THEM ALL.
>> PAUL SHARI, AUTHOR OF "ARMY
OF NONE" WORKED AT THE PENTAGON
UNTIL 2013.
HE EXPLAINS THE RELATIONSHIP.
>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A DRONE HAS
AS MUCH AUTONOMY AS A
SELF-DRIVING CAR?
AND HOW MUCH AUTONOMY DO WE GIVE
TO MACHINES WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
LIFE AND DEATH DECISIONS?
>> AT THE PENTAGON SAYS
HUMAN BEINGS WILL STILL SELECT
THE TARGETS BUT WITH AN
ARTIFICIAL ARMS RACE UNDERWAY.
THE U.S. MILITARY FEARS LEFT
BEHIND.
CHINA HAS ORDERED ITS TECHNOLOGY
GIANTS TO HELP ADVANCE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
RUSSIA IS DEVELOPING FLEETS OF
ARMED ROBOTS AND HAS DEPLOYED
ROBOTIC TANKS TO SYRIA.
GOOGLE'S ERIC SCHMIDT SITS ON
THE PENTAGON DEFENSE INNOVATION
BOARD AND, GOOGLE SAYS PROJECT
MAVEN IS FOR A QUOTE